yep i am standing somewhere windswept
and talking about infrastructure i have
a style also that washing sound you can
hear
that's the other turbine that you can't
see in this camera shot anyway power
grids they have to balance supply and
demand i've talked about that a few
times in the past here but as a quick
catch up if there's not enough power
being generated things break but if
there's too much power being generated
things also break and arguably in a
worse way there isn't a battery in the
world big enough to deal with daily
peaks and troughs of national demand so
power grid engineers have to make sure
that the power being generated is always
close to the power that's being used
there are a lot of possible technologies
to help with that balance and i've
talked about some of those before here
too pumped storage that uses a lake as a
giant battery or even the big lithium
ion setup in australia that's only
caught on fire once so far but all of
those technologies assume that supply
and demand will balance each other out
over time usually over a few hours
what happens if you always have too much
power
welcome to the orkney islands in the far
northeast of scotland about 22 000
people live here on around a thousand
windswept square kilometers and they
have so much renewable energy from wind
and waves and tides that it's genuinely
a problem
solution number one is
turn off the turbines 2013 we were
producing uh up to 130 percent of our
electrical needs so there can be quite a
lot of curtailment on several turbines
there's active network management the
wind turbine will be shut down because
the network can't handle the load
there's been a moratorium on any new
grid connections there is potential for
some micro generation but nothing of any
skill so with when you're in a place
like orkney where you have some of the
best generation potential it's a
complete waste turning off the turbines
isn't a good solution it's wasteful
depending on the time of day and year
these islands need between 7 and 46
megawatts it's almost always windy here
so a couple of big commercial wind farms
like this can produce all the power the
folks here need
but they've also got 500 domestic
turbines privately owned one in 12
households generate their own power
because why wouldn't you once you've
paid the installation cost you'll
probably turn a profit year after year
after year
one of the things i struggled with
writing this script is that there is so
much going on up here there's an
electric hybrid plane being tested at
the airport there are tidal power
experiments wave power experiments every
type of renewable energy almost is being
tested here there's not much solar and
as a backup for the very rare days when
the wind is calm there are
interconnected cables that can pull up
to 40 megawatts from the scottish
mainland
but okay they're generating a massive
surplus of power and they're connected
to the british national grid so surely
solution number two is use those
interconnectors they can just sell the
extra power back to the mainland
well those 40 megawatts that the
interconnectors can handle that's not
actually all that much the
interconnector cables we've got are
small we reckon there's 2 000 megawatts
of tidal and wave generation around here
we reckon there's 17 000 megawatts of
offshore wind within a couple of hundred
kilometers here the interconnect was
built for an old day when used to burn
coal and send us electricity that's gone
we don't do that anymore we now need to
be in a position where we've got a
better way to get the power from these
islands away if the new interconnector
is built it would carry enough power for
all the turbines orkney could reasonably
put up in the next few years they could
power most of the highlands of scotland
but building that new interconnector
will cost a quarter of a billion pounds
national government requires that the
islands approve plans for enough new
turbines to make sure it's going to be
used before it's approved that's all
still in the balance politically so
solution number three is that the
islands could start using more
electricity there's already a larger
share of electric cars here than
anywhere else in scotland but most
vehicles still use petrol or diesel that
could change there's still a lot of oil
heating the ferries vital for getting
around still burn fossil fuels the
transition is a slow process no one's
going to scrap perfectly good car or
heater or ferry unless they have to but
there are plans and orkney's also had a
hydrogen fuel system for years to help
soak up a bit of the excess power we're
producing hydrogen from effectively
spare electricity that's why we started
taking electricity putting it into fresh
water and it splits the water into
hydrogen and oxygen we're getting rid of
the oxygen and we're just capturing the
hydrogen we're compressing it and then
we're using it in this fuel cell
we have ferries that operate within the
islands one of those ferris is able to
be powered by this fuel cell when it
ties up alongside at night and it saves
it running its own engines or it saves
it drawing power from the from the grid
this is just the start of something this
equipment is experimental and
unbelievable it's not efficient this is
not the best way of doing it but we're
finding our way into new territory we
try and unearth some of the challenges
so that when we scale this equipment up
then then those those faults have been
polished out these islands are years
ahead of the rest of the world this is
the test bed this is a small version of
the changes that the whole planet is
going to make the transition to
renewables is happening faster here in
orkney than i think anywhere else in the
world but as you travel around the
islands it just seems normal nothing's
visibly changed but the lessons that
they're learning here will hopefully
pave the way for the rest of the world
you